le thé à la menthe et le premier film du
jeune réalisateur mais aussi le premier
film d'un jeune comédien qui a débuté au
théâtre de nice puis s'est fait
connaître également plus tard au
festival d'avignon pour se lancer
aujourd'hui dans le septième art son nom
abdel kechiche
il est également le héros du thé à la
menthe que nous présente maintenant
andré grandissent avec kechiche thé à la
menthe c'est un succès à paris salle
sera bientôt j'en suis persuadé à nice
alors est ce que c'est un film avec ou
sans sucre
un film avec beaucoup de sucre je dirais
même mieux le c'est un film qui a vendu
très comique c'est une histoire d'un
jeune algérien qui débarque en france
qui raconte un petit peu à sa famille
qui règne en algérie que tout est beau
ici classé voitures sont quatre pièces
sa mère arrive elle s'aperçoit que il a
un petit peu gonflé les choses est ce
que c'est votre histoire mon histoire
personnelle et non pas du tout parce que
moi j'ai grandi ici à nice j'ai toute ma
famille installée ici amis et mon
histoire et pas du tout comparable à
celle de ce jeune garçon jamais l'argent
aux côtes a rien de mieux à faire
d'autre et bien j'en ai marre des roues
de secours
alain tu m'excuses l'a vraiment une
lettre je comprends pas et lorsque c'est
un film un petit peu raciste ou
politiques vous aborder ces problèmes
non justement c'est un film qu'a voulu
éviter tous ces clichés qu'on a déjà un
peu trop bu je crois au cinéma c'est un
film qui montre la france sous ses beaux
jours le réalisateur pense qu'il ya en
france un pourcentage assez minime de
gens racistes je ne sais pas je dirais
un ou deux pourcent et je ne verrais pas
pourquoi on montrait toujours 5 2% de
raciste moi j'ai des amis ici en france
qui sont français et qui sont pas
racistes du tout pourquoi ne pas les
montrer que justement vous avez commencé
à nice au théâtre maintenant vous êtes
lancé dans le cinéma vous avez un autre
projet de film
où il est sûr j'ai des projets mais ça
je ne vous le dirais pas une cache
version à part si pire comme tous les
comédiens